because in this position that looks
absolutely normal here pumpy played the
move with advancing with the pawn
sacrificing upon it's the Temptation
here and Arena crash Falls for it
Peter suggested it's a fork you have to
capture it you end up losing a lot of
material and a check is on the board as
you pointed out if the king's sidesteps
there's a huge mate coming in with that
with this and now notice how the bishop
is spinned you butt up to the bishop
there's a meeting one that's been
threatened on this big Square the only
way to defend it give a check and it's
all been played great ball there the
king side step and now the only move
usually you found it Peter mentioned it
the queen has to fall back to defend the
mate it's been played yeah
we missed and the Players missed as well
and uh this deserves a special mention
one move ago when when Black just gave
the first check from the C5 Square there
is a very clean Victory there which I
didn't see
you can actually play Rook to E3 here
wow and that would have been
the game game of the turn
we're giving up a full Rook here just to
distract the queen and let it not not
let it get to f8 yeah if black takes the
screen with check
let us first point out you can't take it
with the night you come in on the way
and then white is the one delivering the
Checkmate
yeah yeah if you take with the queen I
guess we go King H1 I'm assuming other
moves are also winning but I think H1 is
slightly cleaner than H2 and black just
has no way to connect with the bishop on
G7 yeah uh and amazing we crashed
through and we win and if the queen goes
to f8 anyway which is what uh Irina
crash has done in the game we now have
the move Rook G3
yeah which is not available to hampi in
the game stunning uh and that is that
would have been a fantastic combination
the one that would go into every single
uh book of best games of the of the year